et j'étais une personne très homophobe, il
n'y a aucun doute là-dessus, alors j'ai
pensé qu'il n'y avait pas grand-chose Je vais le soigner
Je trouverai le meilleur centre de traitement
du pays
Je trouverai le remède et je m'en
occuperai
[Musique]
c'est mon premier mariage gay au fait
et pour beaucoup d'entre vous, c'est peut-être votre
premier mariage gay à assister en 1997
J'étais l'un des pères les plus chanceux autour de
mon fils était major de promotion Spelling Bee
champion UT plan pour jouer le grand
travail en tant que Roméo et il m'a en fait attiré
parce qu'il a activement fait du bon travail en tant que
Roméo et Juliette et qu'il n'avait pas de Laura, je
veux dire que tout le monde a la petite amie
lui et une petite amie là-bas et ceci et
cela et j'ai dit Parag est un si pur  mec mec
j'ai tellement de chance et il faisait
tout ce qu'il était passionné par
les gens il était passionné par différentes
personnes j'ai dit que Dieu me souriait vraiment
pour donner un enfant merveilleux comme celui-ci
il avait l'habitude de jouer Bharat Natyam nous avions
même l'habitude de jouer ça  différent cet
événement à l'AMC est un joker à cette
époque il n'y avait pas beaucoup de compétition
mais le fait est que c'était le meilleur
du temps et tout à coup c'est devenu le
pire du temps le 27 mars à
16h25.  ce vendredi soir mais je reçois un
tout petit discours qu'ils n'ont pas fait maman je suis
gay je le sais depuis que j'ai 10
ans je pensais que j'étais confus mais je
commence à réaliser que je le suis encore je
pensais que je le ferais  cache mon homosexualité jusqu'à ta
mort pour ne pas être gêné
mais il a essayé, mais la semaine dernière, je
discutais dans la classe et il y avait
une autre fille indienne et j'ai laissé échapper que je
suis gay, donc je savais que la nouvelle
vous parviendrait tôt ou tard, donc je
vous dis que je suis gay, tout était
comme  discours de trois minutes du meilleur
de l'époque notre vie est allée au pire
de l'époque et j'étais une personne très homophobe il
n'y a aucun doute à ce sujet alors j'ai
pensé qu'il n'y avait pas de problème je vais
le réparer je trouverai le meilleur traitement  centre
dans le pays
je trouverai le remède
et je m'en occuperai lundi matin j'ai été
la première personne à entrer dans la
bibliothèque médicale et j'ai sorti tous les cumulus
médicaux c'est à dire tous les articles
ils sont tous listés dans un seul livre  pendant les
cinq dernières années pour G et H et tout ça et
j'ai commencé à chercher l'article et
puis j'ai soudainement réalisé en 30 minutes
que l'American Psychological Association
en 1973 avait déclaré que les
homosexuels n'étaient pas une maladie ce n'était pas un
défaut ce n'était pas  être guéri, ce n'est pas
contagieux et si vous acceptez que quelqu'un soit
gay, votre enfant ne sera probablement pas plus
gay qu'autrement.
une longue pause et
la réponse était non je l'aime toujours autant
alors j'ai écrit une lettre et quand j'ai
écrit une lettre c'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai dit
qui seront les cinquante personnes qui ont
joué le rôle important dans la
vie de Prague certains d'entre eux  ils sont très conservateurs
quand je savais qu'ils piqueraient
quand ils l'entendraient alors j'ai en quelque sorte pensé d'
accord, peut-être que cinquante pour cent des gens
ne me parleraient pas et ma vie
serait vraiment isolée quoi refaire quelques
minutes plus tard la réponse est venue  très
simple
j'ai dit Vijay s'il y a 50%
des gens qui ne veulent pas vous parler
peut-être qu'ils n'ont pas besoin d'être dans votre vie
pourquoi ne restez-vous pas avec les 50
% restants qui seront avec vous
[  Musique]